what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and
everything mcu and we just got episode
six
of one division and i must say one
division does an
incredible job at giving you a little
bit more details
each time but also making it still
confusing enough to make you crave the
next episode for answers
and one division episode 6 did not
disappoint
there is so much packed into one episode
calls to the fantastic four to the x-men
slash the mutants
calls to mephisto and nightmare and it
appears that we have found out the way
that the mutants are going to be
entering the marvel cinematic universe
all of these things plus a ton of easter
eggs packed into one
episode of wanda vision so let's not
waste any time let's begin with our
breakdown but if you're new to the
channel and you love marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest one division videos and
breakdowns
so this week actually starts off with an
intro
previous episodes would start off with a
scene before we got the actual intro but
we are now
in the 90s and the one division episode
starts off with its
intro and it is straight from malcolm in
the middle
it starts with wanda and vision son's
tommy turning on a camera
90s music blaring in the background then
it goes to each character introducing
them
just like malcolm in the middle did but
what's really interesting
about this intro is what the lyrics of
this song are actually saying
if you listen closely and turn on the
captions they are actually telling us
what is happening
in one division giving us a better idea
of what is going on
the lyrics say don't try and fight the
chaos don't question
what you've done the game can try to
play us
don't let it stop the fun now a few
episodes ago we learned that wanda
is really responsible for all of this
and she's controlling everybody but she
may not realize that she's actually
doing it or at least she didn't realize
it at first as we go to find out later
on in this episode when she's talking
with who we
believe to be quicksilver at this point
she does go on to admit that it's her
but more on that in just a bit but the
lyrics don't try
and fight the chaos don't question what
you've done don't let it stop the fun
refers to what wanda has done and is
currently doing right now
in the hexagon out of chaos which by the
way wanda's magic
is chaos magic so she made everything
happen out of her chaos magic
created the perfect reality for herself
from her chaos magic but she hasn't
stopped and really questioned it she's
kind of just
went with it not stopping it not
stopping the fun or her perfect reality
she didn't really care how she got in
this perfect reality
she just cared that she was in it the
lyrics of the theme go on to say
some days it's all confusion easy come
and easy go but if it's all
illusion sit back enjoy the show now at
this point i think it's established that
this isn't exactly an
illusion that wanda is going through
this is actually happening in the real
world
sword exists and so do all of the other
people that she is controlling so the
illusion that they're actually referring
to
is wanda's illusion of her perfect
reality when in fact it is an illusion
and not reality at
all the truth is she's actually
controlling people and hurting them
but the illusion is her perfect life now
in some episodes she has
questioned this and has been a little
bit confused which is what they're
referring to
but for the most part she's just kind of
gone with it which is the lyric
sit back enjoy the show and then it
repeatedly says
let's keep it going through each
distorted day let's keep it going
wanda doesn't want to lose this perfect
life where she has a vision who is now
all of a sudden alive and she's married
to him and she has twin boys she lives
in the perfect little town
and the perfect little house and her
life is perfect so she's going to do
everything she can to keep it going and
the final lyrics to the song read
though there may be no way of knowing
who's coming by to play and of course
this is a reference to
quicksilver but not exactly the version
that was her brother he came
unexpectedly and
not in true form now later on
quicksilver would go on to break the
fourth wall and talk about how
holiday episodes of old classic sitcoms
and shows would have special guest
appearances
and this is the halloween episode which
would make quicksilver the special guest
speaking of halloween this is the
halloween episode and we see
many different characters in their comic
accurate costumes
billy and tommy are really wiccan and
speed in the comics
each character is dressed up like their
actual character dresses in the comics
or at least pretty close to it
billy looks just like his comic
counterpart wiccan tommy doesn't exactly
have a comic accurate speed costume
however he is mimicking his uncle
quicksilver's costume which is
insanely comic accurate really this is
just
super cool to see on screen wanda and
vision are also
insanely close to their comic accurate
counterparts however we did see these in
the trailers already still
very cool thing for marvel to do wanda
says that her costume
is a sokovian fortune teller obviously
she's not going to say i am the scarlet
witch from marvel comics although i
think everybody would have freaked out
if she did
and vision is apparently dressed as a
mexican wrestler
but hey wanda seems to like it she says
megusta mucho which means she likes it
very much
and vision not really knowing any
spanish replies with
chili con carne which translates to
chili with meat which i guess
vision could be calling himself beef
stew which again who am i to question
because it seems like wanda still enjoys
that very much
now right off the bat we start to notice
the different personalities of the twin
boys
billy starts off by talking about family
and friendship and tommy
starts talking about being cool and
candy so it seems like billy is a lot
like
his mother and tommy is a lot like his
uncle which makes sense considering the
fact that tommy is going to go on to
have powers like his uncle he can run
really really fast and billy will go on
to have powers like his mother so it
seems like their personalities have
transferred a little bit as well
quicksilver is still there as the really
cool uncle we have a really really funny
scene of quicksilver and the twins
shotgunning sodas vision makes the
statement you never told me about your
brother i had no idea he was so
good with kids and wanda says that he's
just full of surprises now this
of course is referring to the version of
which quicksilver that we got in one
division this is obviously not aaron
taylor johnson's version of quicksilver
that we got in age of ultron but it is
in fact
evan peters from the x-men universe so
it is her brother but it's not
which is surprising to wanda now vision
breaks into wanda that he will not be
participating in trick-or-treating with
the family
he says that he has to go help with the
neighborhood watch but of course we find
out that this is a lie and in fact he's
really going to go on and try to escape
he wants to find out what is outside of
west view and he knows that wanda won't
let him leave so he lies so he can get
away from her
and of course wanda is not thrilled
about that and she even says
that's not what you're supposed to do
again she's in her perfect
reality or what is supposed to be her
perfect reality and in that reality
vision is going trick-or-treating with
the kids not going to do neighborhood
watch
duty wanda clearly upset says you never
told me and vision
is starting to get somewhat of a
backbone and he says well i'm telling
you now
it's very clear that since the last
episode there's only been more and more
friction growing between wanda and
vision and then
billy steps in and confirms this and he
looks right into the camera as he says
it doing a fourth wall break that would
make even deadpool proud
juan is upset but quicksilver is very
quick to jump in and say that he'll go
trick-or-treating with the family
and he even says that the twins need a
father figure
now there are tons of theories out there
stating that
quicksilver could actually be the demon
mephisto someone who i've said i believe
is really behind this entire thing and
the reason that he could be behind it is
that in the comics he wants wanda's kids
because they're actually part of his
soul
so this quicksilver father figure
comment is
very very interesting then he makes
another comment stating that he has the
all
x y chromosome this is a direct
reference to his mutant
genes the x gene as it's called in the
comics now of course evan peters's
quicksilver was an
x-men from the fox x-men universe so
technically he does have that
x mutant gene and this isn't the only
time that
mutants and genes are mentioned and
we'll get to that in just a bit
vision finally leaves and he tells wanda
to be good because he knows that she's
the one controlling everybody
and subsequently hurting them vision
leaves and wanda is clearly not happy as
you can tell by the look on her face and
this look
actually looks like it's pretty evil
vision isn't cooperating with
wanda and her perfect reality he's kind
of messing things up
and wanda does not like that once he
leaves wanda turns around and
quicksilver
jump scares her possibly hinting more
that he is truly a villain
but as of right now it just seems like
he's the rad uncle quicksilver now some
people have noted a
tattoo on his left shoulder it looks
like it could say
mom or mom or hom
standing for house of m the comic story
line that has a heavy influence on the
story of wanda vision
or if it is mom it could stand for
multiverse of madness which we do know
that this show will lead up to
however this most likely really doesn't
mean anything as this
is an actual real tattoo that he has in
real life
but at the same time they could have
removed it but chose to keep it in
probably because they knew people like
me would try to dissect every single
little thing and this would probably
drive them crazy so it's kind of a cruel
move by marvel
now speaking of moms there is a part
where quicksilver mentions his and
wanda's mom
and he mentions an old memory and we get
a flashback however
wanda says that she doesn't exactly
remember it that way
giving us a hint that this may not
exactly be
her actual brother even though he is
trying to play the part but then he
tells her
you probably suppressed a lot of the
drama and wanda kind of just brushes it
off but this is actually something that
happens in the comics
wanda suppresses a lot and her
subconscious kind of starts to do things
on its own that wanda isn't exactly
aware of which is basically what we're
seeing here wanda doesn't always know
that she's controlling people it's her
subconscious that's doing it
now in this flashback there's a poster
on the left wall
of the house that they're
trick-or-treating at and it has an atom
on it and this could be an easter egg
for
molecule man who has the power to
control atoms
or this could be a call to the fact that
wanda's energy hex changes people on a
molecular level as darcy said
changing the structure of monaco rambo
cells speaking of darcy the next scene
that we have
goes to outside of wanda's hex to the
sword base
here darcy monica and jimmy are all very
upset that hayward launched a missile on
wanda in the previous episode
and here we actually learn a little bit
more about hayward
monica jimmy and darcy seem to think
that wanda is the solution and not
actually bad when hayward thinks that
she is indeed bad
and we're starting to get the vibe that
he doesn't like as he calls them
super powered individuals he says monica
is an
impediment to the mission because she
likes super super-powered individuals
quoting her
old relationship with carol danvers aka
captain marvel
then he reveals that he was not snapped
he says all you people who left have the
luxury of optimism meaning all of the
people that got snapped during those
five years
he gives us a little glimpse of what
those five years were like apparently it
was insanely hard
as one could imagine it would be he
makes a jab at monica
and her dead mother then he has jimmy
darcy and monica herself
escorted out of the sword base at this
point i don't think hayward is somebody
like mephisto or nightmare more along
the lines of he's somebody who just
hates super powered individuals and as
we find out later is actually tracking
vision so he most likely had his own
agenda with vision
so therefore is even more upset with
wanda fueling his hatred towards those
super powered individuals because she's
the one who broke in and took vision
hayward kicks them out but don't you
worry because jimmy wu
is the freaking man as soon after he
goes to town
beating up all of the sword agents that
are around him with the help of monica
back in wonderland we cut to the family
trick-or-treating and there are just a
ton
of easter eggs in these scenes the first
one we see is a house that is apparently
alluding to witches
and probably agatha harkness we see a
black cat which is a call to
agatha harkness's cat named ebony now
agatha's cat ebony had pretty special
powers it could sense when other
mystical beings were around it
and it could even turn into a massive
black panther much like this inflatable
black cat that we see here
also in the yard are three witches
surrounding a cauldron and if you notice
there are also
witch's hats hanging from the roof we
get at marvel there are witches
involved with one division wanda herself
is a witch the scarlet witch and of
course agatha harkness is as well
now as we go through these scenes there
are many different costumes there are
skeletons there are mummies there are
genies
and of course there is billy tommy wanda
and what seems to be a
very evil looking quicksilver then from
that evil looking quicksilver we get an
insanely
huge line drop as the twins run away to
go trick-or-treating quicksilver says
unleash hell demon spawn now after
this line was dropped by quicksilver
it's going to be pretty hard to convince
me and i'm sure a lot of people that
mephisto is not involved in this
in some way shape or form like i said
mephisto
wants wanda's kids in the comics because
they are technically a part of him he is
the one who kind of got her pregnant
but in a magical way not physical so the
twins were a part of him they were
his spawn and mephisto is a demon
quicksilver is literally calling the
twin boys the spawn of
a demon and saying to unleash hell which
the hell realm is what mephisto controls
and rules
now quicksilver has a very weird hairdo
going on here now you could say
it's like the original quicksilver in
the comics but what if these are
actually made to look this way because
they're actually trying to make them
look
like horns again pointing that mephisto
a devil
or demon could actually be quicksilver
in disguise or could simply be the one
behind everything
and we get more evidence for this
throughout the rest of the episode
wanda still is kind of weary of
quicksilver and she tries to test him
asking him questions about their
childhood talking about a person who had
a weird skin thing who tried to steal
his boots
now the weird skin thing could be a
reference to dr doom
who could have ties with sokovia in the
mcu
we'll have to wait to find out about
that later but quicksilver
realizes what she's doing he says you're
testing me and he says hey it's cool i
know i
look different and wanda doesn't really
know why and she asks him why
and his reaction is i wouldn't want to
be reminded of the past
either kind of avoiding the question and
wanda doesn't really like the answer but
before you know it quicksilver is off
with the kids collecting candy
but before he takes off and before that
line he mentions
shangri-la now shangri-la in the comics
is a place that was founded by vision
and vision rules over it
vision discovered the secrets of death
and life
gave himself immortality and made a
pledge to protect
mankind this is something that we see
happening in one division
vision is resurrected he was dead now
he's alive and he tells agatha in a
scene not too far from here that he will
try to help everybody from here things
start to escalate
pretty quickly wanda talks to herb who
was on the neighborhood watch and
figures out that vision
isn't actually working with the
neighborhood watch like he said he was
now a few things to notice as herb is
talking one is that there's a kid in a
costume that looks an
awful lot like hobgoblin and the other
is that there's a figure that's a prop
and a yard that seems to be
looking at wanda now this figure kind of
looks like it could resemble
the grim reaper or death implying that
the grim reaper could indeed be
a villain and is kind of looking at
wanda this whole entire time and this is
noticed at different angles as she's
talking to herb
now herb doesn't seem to be just a
normal citizen here
if you noticed he actually heard about
everything that's happening with
quicksilver and the twin boys
before they actually happen he says like
and now everybody's covered in silly
string and then it happens behind him
and even more interesting is that before
he leaves he says
is there something i can do for you
wanda do you want something changed
so it appears that herb is aware that
wanda is controlling what is happening
around
this was also demonstrated in an earlier
one division episode where herb
and agnes were talking about geraldine
and herb was going to drop the line
we're all and now we know that he was
going to say something like
we're all trapped or we're all being
controlled by a hex
except herb and agnes don't really seem
to be that controlled by it
or are they we cut the vision who is now
seemingly noticing
all of the children around if you recall
in episode 5
vision asked why there were no other
children in the town so before this
episode
no other children existed he continues
to walk down the street and he starts to
notice that the people are acting kind
of funny as he gets further from wanda
he notices that the people aren't really
moving
and they're repeating the same behavior
over and over again like the woman
hanging up close on the clothesline
isn't really hanging new things up she's
just going back and forth between one
item
and he notices that she is crying and
this is most likely due to the fact that
she's probably in pain
due to wanda controlling her this was
revealed by norm in the last episode of
one division where he said
it really hurts whatever she is doing we
then have a very weird and
90s commercial there's a kid stuck on an
island at sea who is starving
a shark pops up and says he can fix his
starvation with
yo magic the only problem is he can't
get it opened and eventually dies
because of this
and this seems to be a metaphor for what
is happening inside of wanda's reality
because you have to wonder these are
real people that she has taken over and
they don't seem to have any control over
themselves
are they actually able to eat this could
be a very literal commercial
where wanda's magic is actually going to
end up killing these people
or it could be a metaphor for how
wanda's magic won't actually give her
what she needs
a fake reality that is seemingly
temporary isn't going to help her in
real life
the next one we have is of wanda
quicksilver and the twin boys walking
down the street and a theater is in the
background and you can see that it says
the incredibles and
the parent trap now this is actually a
fantastic for
easter egg as the incredibles was a
movie that is actually a homage to the
fantastic
four this is something that pixar
themselves even recognized and the
parent trap could be referring to a trap
that is set for wanda
the parent of the twin boys who could
partially belong to the villain like
mephisto
and this could be a trap set by him now
from here we learn a little bit more of
why
quicksilver is there he's basically
there to stir up trouble
and to create grief for wanda and he
says that's what you wanted wasn't it
this takes wanda back a little bit and
then marvel adds such a clever line here
wanda asks pedro what happened to his
accent and petro asks
what happened to yours now when wanda
was first introduced in age of ultron
she had a sokovian accent
along with her brother but she lost that
accent after age of ultron we didn't
hear it in civil war
infinity war or end game and fans have
been wondering
why it went away and this is marvel's
way of acknowledging that
we then get a little bit more background
of how quicksilver exactly got there he
says he was shot up referring to aaron
taylor johnson's quicksilver and age
voltron and the next thing you know
he heard wanda calling him now if he
truly is a villain this very well could
be a lie
and if you notice his eyes are kind of
red and his skin does have a bit of a
red tint to it
implying that he could indeed be the
villain but if he's not
it does look like wanda has somehow
revived him
in some way perhaps using a summoning
ritual or hex of some sort
now she stated in the last episode that
she couldn't just bring somebody back to
life that there were rules and perhaps
that's why we see the evan peters
version of quicksilver and not aaron
taylor johnson's from age of ultron
because he's dead
and she can't exactly revive him but
perhaps take a quick silver from a
different universe
then right after this we discovered that
tommy has super powers he has super
speed
just like his uncle quicksilver billy's
powers haven't shown yet but don't worry
we get to them
in just a bit before they leave though
wanda says don't go
past ellis street this comes back up
later with vision
but in the meantime darcy jimmy and
monica are trying to figure out a way to
try and get back
inside of the hex in which we get one of
the biggest easter eggs in mcu history
now darcy is way different than the
person that we knew from thor 1
and thor 2. she's a doctor now and she
manages to hack into the system's
security of sword
pretty easily and she discovers that
hayward has figured out a way to
actually look inside of the hexagon and
he's tracking
vision specifically the decay signature
of vibranium
of course these are things that he did
not tell the sword team which leads us
to believe even more that he
is a villain of some sort now i
personally believe
that hayward is trying to make some sort
of a weapon out of vision this is why he
was experimenting with him
vision was originally supposed to be
ultron and it looks like hayward could
be trying to rebuild ultron but also by
the sounds of decaying
vibranium it sounds like a vision may
not actually be fully back to life and
may be falling apart
now vision and darcy jimmy and monica
discover that
the people who aren't close to wanda but
are on the outer edges
of the hexagon aren't really moving and
the reason for this is because if you
recall
sword looks at everything through a tv
everything in wanda's reality is
projected as a sitcom
and anything that isn't on screen in the
sitcom
isn't needed and therefore isn't moving
so basically these people can only
really move if they're around wanda
vision changes out of his halloween
costume and into the normal vision that
we know and then he finds
agnes now here she seems to be under
wanda's control despite
in previous episodes not being under her
control vision seemingly
awakens her and she says you're an
avenger are you here to save us
and he says he is but he doesn't know
what an avenger is and this is because
he can't remember anything before
westview before wanda resurrected him
now agnes
seems genuinely confused here almost
like she was truly awakened
then we get the scene that we saw in the
trailers where she asked if she's dead
because
vision is vision is confused and asks
and what and she says
dead and she says it a lot this could
tie into the theory that the grim reaper
is truly one of the villains of the show
now vision says that he's going to help
but
agnes says how wanda won't even let us
think about leaving
and she says all is lost but then she
laughs very much like a witch
now regardless of whether or not agnes
is good or bad i do believe she is
agatha harkness the witch that takes
care of
wanda envisions twin boys in the comics
now at some points she is clearly not
under wanda's spell
but it appears that she is here so what
could be happening here
is that wanda has actually become too
powerful
agnes may have been free at first but
now that wanda is stronger
agnes can't break through but now a part
of me does think that she is acting
she was there for a specific reason to
talk division perhaps to try and even
push him to get out
because if you notice she was very lost
before vision awakened her but once he
unawakened her and put her back to
normal
she wasn't as lost as she was in the
beginning in fact she turns the car
right around and leaves like she knows
exactly what she's doing
so i think this could have been an act
to push a vision to leave
the energy hex and get wanda to make it
bigger
now vision finds himself on ellis street
which is where wanda told the twins not
to go past and of course that is because
this is the end of her hex energy field
but this is also a call to magneto
if you recall in the first x-men ellis
island was the target of magneto's plan
to turn humans into mutants
and this was ian mckellen's magneto who
we think could actually be the really
big cameo and thank you to my subscriber
andrew chapel for pointing that out last
night
now monica mentions someone who can help
her get through the energy field and she
mentions that
it's a guy now monica did mention an
aerospace
engineer that could help her with the
situation this could be that same person
and this could be
reed richards of the fantastic four mr
fantastic
reed richard is noted as the smartest
marvel character smarter than tony stark
bruce banner shuri he's the smartest and
part of his
genius is aerospace engineering and
perhaps that huge
cameo that both elizabeth olsen and paul
bettany have been talking about
could be whoever is going to play reed
richards of the fantastic four
now here's where we get that huge x-men
mutant easter egg monica wants to go
back inside the hex but
darcy says you can't then she points out
monica's blood samples
and she says that the energy inside has
rewritten her cells on a molecular
level twice because she had to go
through the energy field twice
once when she went in once when she went
out and darcy says that it's
changing her this ladies and gentlemen
is how the mutants
will exist in the marvel cinematic
universe the power from
the energy which is said to be from the
big bang and remember the big bang
created the infinity stones so therefore
we believe the energy to be from the
infinity stones which awoken
wanda's powers this same energy is
awakening the powers
within monica who in the comics is the
superhero
photon who has a vast amount of powers
kevin feige has confirmed the mutants
coming to the mcu we have been wondering
for a very long time
how exactly they're going to come into
the picture and this is apparently how
now we know that wanda's hex gets bigger
at the end of this episode so she can
save vision it's my theory that
eventually
this hex will go across the entire world
activating the x mutant gene inside of
all those who possess it therefore
creating the mutants now we cut back to
wanda and quicksilver again
and he again shows us that he's aware of
everything that's going on
he knows that wanda has created all of
this and wanda asks him if he thinks
it's wrong what she's doing now fully
aware that it's her in control and he
says
no he's impressed this hints that again
he's not
actually quicksilver it looks like he
wants wanda to continue to create these
things
to control this reality he does drop the
avengers age of
ultron easter egg though he says this is
a lot more impressive than giving people
nightmares and shooting red wigglies out
of her fingers which is what she did in
age of ultron to the avengers now he
tries to get all cozy up with wanda
talking about how their family but then
she sees a dead quicksilver just like
she did with
vision which i think could be nightmare
nightmare feeds off of fear
and what better way to bring fear to
wanda than to show her
her dead husband and her dead brother
now before we talk about the final scene
there is one fantastic for easter egg
darcy stays behind to look at some more
files and one of the project folders
that she pulls up
is labeled project r4123
and this may be a coincidence but this
could be referring to
the fantastic four number one two three
in the comics it's a story about the
fantastic
four the silver surfer galactus and
agatha harkness
and since there seemed to be a few
fantastic four easter eggs in there
perhaps this is hinting as what's to
come in the future of marvel studios
and thanks to my subscriber victor
herrera for finding this one out darcy
also finds a file labeled cataract
classified weapons intel furthermore
proving that hayward is using vision to
develop weapons
now vision manages to escape the energy
hex
however he is not able to escape for
long as it starts to pull him back in
now it looks like the energy from the
hex is actually what is keeping vision
alive and that could be why wanda
set up this perimeter so vision could
live but he escapes and he starts to die
but thankfully wanda's little boy billy
has developed his powers which are the
power of telepathy and telekinesis much
like his mother has and he can hear his
father dying
now wanda realizes what's happening
realizes that vision got out of the
energy hex and she
expands it and she doesn't just expand
it for a little bit it looks like she
expands it for miles now unfortunately
darcy was handcuffed to one of the
trucks and she gets sucked in but we
don't see the outcome for her but we do
see some sword agents get sucked in and
they turn
into circus people which shows us how
wanda views sword she doesn't really
take them seriously
but monica and jimmy manage to escape
and hayward with some sword agents
escape as well
now from here it's very clear that wanda
really is responsible for
let's say a majority of everything
that's going on and it's clear that
vision has to stay inside of the energy
field
to stay alive now again i think this
energy hex is going to be how the
mutants come into the mcu
and i think that by the end of one
division wanda is going to cover the
entire earth with this energy
awakening all of the mutants it's very
clear that she has the power to do so
they're still making us believe that
wanda is going to be the main villain
however i'm not buying it i still think
there is somebody else behind this
like nightmare mephisto or the grim
reaper but let me know your theories in
the comments down below let me know what
you thought about one division episode
six
don't forget to subscribe for more
marvel content don't forget to like the
video and share it with your friends if
you enjoyed it for live updates you can
find me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you